LeBron James and Kyrie Irving were this
close to getting the band back together
and last year Kyrie went to an extreme
to try and make it happen because his
season ended early Kyrie bought
courtside seats to the Lakers Grizzlies
playoff game knowing it was a good way
to mentally and physically get to LeBron
and Pitch him an idea that he thought he
could not refuse Kyrie was a free agent
at the time the Lakers were in the
market for a new point guard it all made
sense but there was one problem the MAV
still owned his bird rights and the team
was still determined to make the pair
work between him and Luca so leaving in
the offseason wouldn't be as easy as we
thought plus the Lakers also wanted to
try running things back with the same
core that had a deep postseason the
season before but with the Lakers
current season being up and down and the
way that Kyrie has been balling since
coming back from injury maybe getting
Kyrie would have been the best thing to
do